code reuse is a central tenant of
software development machine learning
should be no different
stay tuned to find out how to use test
referral hub to easily load up and
customize state-of-the-art models in
your tensor flow code
welcome to AI adventures where we
explore the art science and tools of
machine learning my name is Yu Feng Guo
and on this episode we're gonna check
out tensorflow hub developing state of
the art machine learning models is no
easy feat large state of the art models
require lots of carefully curated
balanced data to train and they take a
long time to train as well now test our
four hub is a library for the
publication discovery and consumption of
reusable parts of machine learning
models the primary use case for the
models in TF hub is for transfer
learning transfer learning is a
technique to base your machine learning
models on other large models pre trained
on even larger datasets this enables you
to train your particular customized
model on a smaller data set improve
generalization and speed up the training
process so that you're not starting from
scratch because TF hub is integrated
with tensorflow you end up pulling in
sections of a tensor flow graph and so
the library makes it super easy to load
up these models to be fine-tuned the
resources in TF hub are known as modules
a module is imported into a tensor flow
program by creating a module object from
a string with it's either URL or file
system path that's shown now there are
already many models available on TF hub
with more on the way the two broad
categories of model types available
today are images and text the image
models are trained extensively to
classify objects and images and by
reusing their feature detection
capabilities you can create models that
recognize your own custom classes using
much less training data
time then it took to make those more
advanced models some of the image models
available today include Inception v1 v2
and v3 mobile net in all sorts of
configurations Nass net and penis net as
well as resonant most of these models
were at one point state of the art image
classification models and they serve as
great starting points for many image
based machine learning applications now
the text base models they're no slouch
either currently there's the universal
sentence encoder Elmo which is a model
trained on the 1 billion word benchmark
nn/lm which is a neural network language
model trained on the Google News data
set so yeah there's some pretty cool
models on tensorflow hub okay two final
apps specs that I want to cover about
test referral hub are the guides to
using the modules which very important
and how you can publish your own modules
to the hub first the TF hub website has
a number of great guides that show you
how to load up and find two models for
your use case for example this guide
here shows how to do text classification
of movie reviews with the nn/lm model
you can take this and easily swap out
the data set the model or both to your
liking so TF hub it can't be a hub
without your contribution as you develop
new and interesting models with your own
data consider creating a TF hub module
that others can then reuse you might
find collaborators who can improve upon
your models even further or discover use
cases that you hadn't thought of TF hub
is not just a place to find machine
learning models it's an entire framework
for publishing and consuming models all
with an easy-to-use and consistent
interface this if you believe is
critical as I think it'll enable us to
think in a higher level of abstraction
this leads to more innovative ways of
remixes and reusing existing models
expanding the possibilities of what is
possible with machine learning thanks
for watching this episode of cloudy high
adventure
and if you enjoyed it please like it and
subscribe to get all the latest episodes
right when they come in for now check
out tests full hub and see how you can
build on top of some of the most
advanced models around